كيف ا
ستتاح ال حرب الدائره في غزه مع عمليه
الاغتيال
لنائب رئيس المكتب
السياسي بدايه نترحم على
اي روح الشهيد الشيخ صالح العاروري القائد
الوطني
الكبير حقيقه ان هذه
العمليه هي احدى ارها صات الانتقال
للمرحله الثالثه من مراحل الحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه قد تكون الاداره
الامريكيه في هذه قد تكون الاداره
الامريكيه غير مطلعه او غير راضيه بشكل او
باخر عن حيثيات هذه العمليه لكن المداولات
التي جرت بين الاداره الامريكيه ودوله
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حول حيثيات الانتقال
للمرحله الثالثه تضمنت في في قلبها وفي
المركز منها عمليات اغتيال مركزه وعمليات
جراحيه لقياده حركه حماس لذلك هذه العمليه
هي تعبير حقيقي عن الفشل الذي منيت الذي
مني به جيش الاحتلال في المرحله الاولى
والمرحله الثانيه من الحرب على قطاع غزه
لذلك خلال الفتره المقبله سنشهد مزيدا من
هذه المحاولات
الاسرائيليه لخلق صور محدده
حول صور نصر اي بعيدا عن ساحه المعركه ال
الاشتباك المباشر الذي شهده القطاع طيله
نحو على مدى ثلاث شهور تقريبا اي هذه
العمليه سيكون لها ايضا انعكاس على
اي الجبهه الشماليه لانها جاءت الان في
وقت حساس وانا اتفق مع ان هذا ان التقيييم
الاسرائيلي لهذه العمليه هو غير مدروس لان
السقف التصعيد اصلا على الجبهه الشماليه
وصل بطبيعه الحال الى حده الاعلى خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه
و وصل الى حده الاعلى ما دون الحرب وهذا
تقييم شخصيه مثل تايمر هايمن الذي يعمل
مستشارا حاليا اللي جلنت ورئيس
الاستخبارات الاسرائيلي السابق
الاستخبارات
العسكريه فهذه العمليه هي عباره عن عن فعل
يتجاوز خطوط او او او او قواعد الاشتباك
التي جرى العمل بها طيله السنوات الماضيه
في المنطقه نحن نتحدث عن العمليه عمليه
الاغتيال اكثر صخبا التي يقوم بها خلال ضد
حركه حماس في خارج فلسطين هي العمليه
الاغتيال لارفع
شخصيه على الاراضي اللبنانيه منذ عام
1992 1992 حينما اختال الاحتلال الامين
العام السابق لحزب الله السيد عباس
الموسوي ا ايضا هذه العمليه بكل ما ما
تتضمنه هي عباره عن هروب بشكل او باخر من
حاله الفشل في قطاع غزه الى ساحات اخرى
ستنعكس بشكل مباشر على الواقع الميداني في
الجبهه الشماليه وسيكون لها تبعات ليست
سهله على الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال
الساعات والايام المقبله